how do I name my YouTube channel three
options first and last name name plus
brand or brand name only so first and
last name your channel could be Shan
canel Tony Robbins shellene Johnson Gary
vaynerchuk Alex Hermos first and last
name it's a personal brand great second
idea your channel could be cooking with
Karen barbecue with Bob cooler if it run
s kind of cool because you get what
you're doing or it also might not make
as much sense it might be like the
future with Fred like what is a
technology Channel I'm not sure what
that is
so I love that because you might even
cut your last name off and put more of
the niche or the brand or something
about it like real estate tips with
Ralph and if you were for some reason
named by your parents with a name that
doesn't rhyme with your Niche I'm sorry
that's me too YouTube tips with Yousef
my name should have been Yousef but my
name is Sean but my Sean canel rhes with
YouTube channel though so okay and then
lastly think
media um other ones you know like a
brand name like so uh you could just
name your channel you know Film Riot you
know and I and it's up to you so here's
the questions when it comes to
deciding is what is it you're ultimately
trying to build what is your long-term
Vision uh if you get into gaming it
sometimes you know it might be like
Razer
55x 22 or you know different Gamers kind
of different culture so kind of
understanding you know what is it you
want to communicate what what is your
what is your dream what is you what do
you want to build and I don't know if
you can actually get it wrong wrong
although I do think if you get it right
it's incredibly helpful like again if
you could go cooking with Karen it's
like oh cool I know her name's Karen and
then I obviously know what the channel
is about it's about cooking so I think
those are a few thoughts at the end of
the day um one other tip I would give
you is if you think like a business
owner and not just like a hobbyist
Creator which is our goal at our company
is no whether you're kind of on the
Creator path you just want to be pure
Creator economy even with an
entertainment Channel or you already are
a business-minded person because you're
a service provider a business
owner all of us need to be thinking like
business owners like Jay-Z said I'm not
a businessman I am a
businessman and a business person would
also say is the website available is the
social media handles available is the
trademark
available where's the where do I want to
build over the next five to 10 years now
you don't have to answer all those
questions because you might be like
relax bro I just want to name myself
like Razer 55 kick Kat you know like
okay you know I don't ever want to have
a website well that would be your vision
then but if you if you were thinking
like I want to build a brand like and
you might just be saying what if like
when sitting down to name a channel you
might say what if this was something
bigger one day like when my friend Benji
and
I um started video influencers which is
kind of like sideline back burner
project but grew to 700,000 subs or
whatever and we you know wrote YouTube
Secrets together before we even posted a
video I think we bought
videoinfluencers.net
eventually for like 12 bucks I think we
got videoinfluencers.net
dot up first but we did the research and
we got the Instagram and we got the
Twitter now X and we got the Facebook
page so we also were thinking about
brand and not just a YouTube channel
name so we actually go um into this in a
very heavy way
inside of our Niche Finder course one of
the best things you could do this month
is go through our Niche Finder course if
you want to get clear on your topic
maybe you're going to Pivot or
reposition your channel a lot of our our
V students you may already have that in
your members area uh but it's also part
of our um bundle as well so I hope those
tips added value and that's one of the
reasons why you don't want to sleep
on our holiday offer because uh there's
I maybe covered half of the Strategic
questions not even of just kind of like
brand Niche where's this going
positioning big picture so th media
sale.com skip the
appetizers pick up the Cyber week sale
think Medias sale.com if you enjoy this
podcast and are ready for some deep dive
YouTube strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my 1H
hour on demand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com